so optimization
is not a good
way to live life
if you thought that it was obviously
clear that that was
the relevant value so obviously clear
that it never even occurred to you to
ask whether it was right to think that
then you would be in danger yeah got it
so yeah there is some in this modern
technological age in in the full meaning
of the word technology that's updated to
actual modern age with
a lot more technology going on
it uh it does feel like
like colleagues of mine in tech space
actually
are somehow drawn to that optimization
as if that's going to save us
as if the thing that truly weighs us
down
is um
the inefficiencies exactly and i i think
if you think about other other contexts
like what what are the moments when
i mean we're unique in this respect this
this period in history is unlike any
previous no nobody ever felt that way
right but think about but it's also true
that nobody no previous period in
history was nihilistic so our condition
is tied up that sort of thing is meant
to be a response to the felt lack of a
ground
and
so no no previous epoch in history
felt that way they didn't have our
problem
but think so so they it was much more
natural to them to experience
moments in ways that feel
um unachievable for us what we were
calling moments of aliveness before
think about where the context in which
they felt them they weren't efficient
optimized contexts think about the the
greeks
if you ever read homer it is a bizarre
world back there but one of the things
that's bizarre
is that they're so unmotivated by
efficiency and optimizing
that
the only thing that seems to run through
all of the different greek cultures is
the idea
that if some stranger comes by
you better
take care of them
because zeus is the is the god of
strangers and zeus will be angry that's
what they say right but what is it how
does it manifest itself
odysseus he's trying to get home and he
gets shipwrecked on an island and you
know he's trying to figure out he's been
at sea for 10 days he's starving he's
been draggled and he sees uh now sissa
the the princess who's beautiful and
he's like boy i better you know i don't
know get to get get some clothes or
something like i don't want them to beat
me up and kill me
and so they so she takes him to the
palace
they have three days of banquets and
festivals before they even ask his name
it's like here's a stranger
our job is to celebrate the presence of
a stranger because this is where
significance lies
now we don't have to feel that way but
but the idea that that's one of the
places where significance could lie is
pretty strongly at odds with the idea
that our salvation is going to come from
optimization and efficiency now maybe
something about the way we live our
lives we'll have that integrated into it
but it's but it's at odds with other
other moments
you